all right guys
bang bang i've got a special treat for
you today
ben is here thank you so much for doing
this sir oh my pleasure
um let's start with uh your background
um you are probably one of the most
educated people who have ever come on
the podcast
uh let's just talk through kind of where
you grew up uh
various schools you went to and get into
kind of your entrepreneurial career
sure sure so i grew up in
cupertino california so the story i like
to tell i was in third grade
we had a class visitor who wanted to
tell us about this new thing he was
working on when it was steve jobs
so that started early but my first
silicon valley job was cutting apricots
um
so it was like 12 and 13 uh
making dried apricots and then they
paved over the orchard and they built
apple
so i had kind of been think of it for a
while but
uh yeah my most my career has been uh
sort of
in startup land uh i've done
eight startups for as a ceo
um and uh you know sort of
uh started out my careers somewhat
different i was actually in uh
in uh uh demography really in my
my first livestream i spent time in
africa
working on uh on sort of rural health
and things like that
uh then went to uzbekistan to try and
start a business school
uh which had as it's uh
you know our business case for the uh
for the business school is that we teach
people how to read a balance sheet and
democracy and free markets will just
happen and that and that didn't quite
work we
you know we managed to teach a bunch of
classes but in every class there was
somebody sitting in the back
wearing a nail fitting suit never
talking taking copious notes and
eventually we uh
you know we ended up getting shut down
the government's done my first mail
startup
um but uh you know since that time i've
been kind of fortunate
uh i was really in web 1-0
working for uh verisign with this crazy
idea
you can do transactions on on the
internet and do so securely
so i ran the uh the security payments uh
um uh businesses for them
then was uh ceo of plaxo early social
networking company
um which eventually we sold to comcast
uh then ceo of bluster which open source
storage company
uh which uh sold red hat then ceo of
docker
which sort of launched the container
revolution for those of you who
those of your listeners were in the
computing space and then most
uh most recently of course i came on
board as as
executive chair um storage which is the
decentralized so we got to talk about
uh africa insurance a continent where
most people don't think to go and and
work
and then uzbekistan is not the place
that most people would think to go build
a business what was the uh
i said what was the genesis for uh for
wanting to go to those two places
uh well so um uh africa
or you know in particular i was in i was
in kenya
and at the time uh kenya had a
uh had a fertility rate of eight which
means that the average woman living
through her childbearing years would
have eight kids
uh so you know for the fastest growing
uh populations on the on
planet and there were 40 different uh
ethnic groups each of which was growing
a slightly different rate and for
political power it kind of depends on
at some level on populations so you know
for me it was a really fascinating idea
like can you can you somehow take math
and caring about people and combine them
and find a way to
intelligently help people and and
actually you know kenya's turned out to
be one of the big success stories
uh uh over the past um you know past
30 years or so in terms of development
including by the way that they
they figured out uh this great
decentralized way of doing finance using
uh
using uh using text messaging so you
know
a ton of banking and lending and sending
money
from the city back home all happens a
text message so it's
pretty exciting second place absolutely
and so when you
finally came back to silicon valley
started working at the technology
companies
just growing up there i'm assuming that
you uh one wanted to work at kind of
these technology companies but two you
had aspirations to one day have your own
as well or was that kind of a
okay and so let's talk maybe about
docker which is kind of the the
last one that you did uh before moving
into kind of the crypto decentralized uh
storage world
um just tell us the story of docker and
kind of how you guys built that company
sure sure um i mean so so docker
um is a uh was it was a company that
actually started life as as uh as
something else it was a
platform as a service company um and
used some underlying technology to do
that
that was a radically different approach
towards how do you sort of
encapsulate workloads if you will um
and um docker was a
uh you had this idea this okay you know
the the way that people build
ship and run code is
it was almost like it was sort of in the
pre-industrial age if you will right
because
code was took a long time to write a
long time to update it was done by large
groups of people
code was tightly tied to
the servers that it ran on and docker
had this idea of sort of
if you want kind of creating the
shipping container equivalent uh for
code right so that you can take
again a piece of code put it in the
equivalent of a digital shipping
container
uh and of course the nice thing about
typical containers in the physical world
is that you know it doesn't matter
what's on the inside the
outside is always the same and always
the same dimension books involved in the
same places so in physical world
if you want to ship goods from point a
to point b you put them in a shipping
container and
goes from a ship to a train to a truck
to a crane without a group
having to be opened um and it can you
know it's revolutionary
shipping and revolutionized physical
transport and docker
really revolutionized the way that um
that code is written and shipped um so
everything you read now about
cloud-native computing and you know
computing at a massive scale where
workloads get split up into lots of
pieces and run all over the place that
was
that was docker we you know get it kind
of in
good decentralized fashion if you will
by building a massive community
and being completely open source and um
you know letting a thousand different
approaches blossom and see which ones
work
and so it was a was an amazing ride
and you know something like
i think the estimates are like 70 of all
new uh code that's written is written
sort of using the sort of docker
kubernetes pattern
what's interesting to me is uh when
people think of docker i don't think
they think of decentralization and kind
of they don't necessarily see
a huge comparison to that and what
you're doing with storage
but there actually was a lot of the same
ethos right there's open source there's
decentralization there's very community
driven
um type thing maybe talk a little bit
about what you know how intentional was
that
versus how you got pulled in that
direction while building building docker
because that's just where you guys saw
traction
yeah no no actually it was really quite
intentional i mean you know i think
uh you know we were if you will
sort of going up against a bunch of
really really large incumbents
um sort of the vmwares and the large
cloud providers we're all doing things
based off of virtual machines um
and a particular way of doing things and
you know we knew that you know a
14-person company is not going to change
that
right but a massive community can't and
so we were really very intentional in
saying hey let's
let's build a big community let's let's
make the code open
let's take a really decentralized
approach and we didn't use
those terms right you know like a really
you know distributed decentralized
approach towards how we build
build the code how it gets adopted we
built lots of really open interfaces
anybody could take the code modify it
use it in ways that they saw
fit and um that enabled us to have
a massive community source bring up
overnight i mean one of the
largest uh projects kind of in the space
of
you know six months if you will right
and
um you know got to the point where
billions of uh
downloads a day were happening of code
that was sort of encapsulated in
in docker and and that is really very
similar to the open to the decentralized
ecos right i mean that you
give up control that you you know you do
everything in the open you make
interfaces clean
um you sort of do sort of individual
empowerment right
individuals to do what they want to do
you set incentives right and then
suddenly magic happens
and that's something you have to do if
you're a challenger as opposed to
absolutely and talk maybe a little bit
about storage so
you know what you did at docker was very
very disruptive i think that there's
been a lot of people
who have said oh all these centralized
uh storage and centralized computing
companies uh are the incumbents uh maybe
one way to disrupt them is through this
decentralized
approach just why go and kind of help
storage and kind of what's the model and
how does it work yeah yeah
well i mean i um i mean the
yeah so start from the the first right i
mean you know death taxes and data are
kind of
like you know the givens in this world
and
this past world the world this past year
the world created enough data
to fill a stack of cd roms that would
stretch to the orbit of mars and back
um and it's going to grow like 40 next
year right so
it's crazy how much data is created um
and yeah some of that a lot of that cat
videos but you know some of that is
really critical information like that
you know
the the cure for government or or you
know
new forms of clean energy and things
like that right um and
you know for most of computing history
data was stored locally so you push
stuff to a hard drive
and then we had the cloud computing
companies start here the
the amazon awss and
microsoft insurers and google gcp
um and they actually started out in
storage they started their first
service all of them offered was store
your data put your data up there and
store it
and um you know i think they're they've
done a great job but there are a bunch
of problems
first of all cloud computing centralized
cloud computing
is by far the incumbent and uh
you know something like 90 on the market
is among those three players
they also happen to be three of the five
largest companies by market cap
right um and there's no income there's
almost nobody has managed to try and
meet them at their games
situation where globally more and more
data is being created more and more data
is being stored
with three largest players we've sort of
created three rockefellers if you will
if data is the new oil
um meanwhile um
prices unsurprisingly they have not come
down right and
in five years basically the price of uh
you know storing a gig of data has only
gone down by about 10
the public cloud meanwhile why is that
i think it's all about play right it's
you've got you got three big players
and they have no incentive for lower
prices because as soon as one of them
lowers when google entered the market
prices went down
and then they stopped right because i
think any one of them lowers prices and
the others match um
so basically by avoiding lowering the
price you avoid the race to zero
exactly right so they're they're
avoiding the race to zero
i'm in and you know to be fair there are
you know cloud storage
costs a lot of money delivered because
you have to build big data centers and
you have to
power them and provide you know fire
suppression all these other sorts of
things
but meanwhile you know as big as cloud
storage is
uh you know it's dwarfed by the amount
of storage that's in disks all over the
planet
um you know something again like 80
of them are less than 25 full
and it takes no more power or people or
energy or capital to take all those
drives that are out there
and you know start using the unused 75
capacity that they have so uh that's a
business idea right
um and and you know at some level we're
basically like a massive airbnb
for disk drives only instead of having
people um
you know rent out spare rooms in their
houses they've been out to spare it's
based on their on their disrupts
so what i want to do real quick is help
people understand
conceptually how a decentralized
storage network works and in order to do
that um
maybe we can take two seconds and just
describe a data center so for those that
don't know
uh there are massive computing
facilities all over the world uh
these facilities basically build um you
know the physical structure they put
computers they put storage
uh hardware uh in those facilities and
then they have sales forces that try to
go out and get customers and so
that model um is can be very profitable
if done well
uh but just like any business uh when
you go to the convenience store
uh you don't have everyone buying all of
the products in the convenience store at
all times so there's things that are
sitting idle or in this world
it is computing power or storage that is
unused
and so this idea of a decentralized uh
storage network is basically
uh ben the tmat storage has come up with
an incentive mechanism to get
the unused storage to come up for
availability
through a digital means and then people
who need storage can go in and basically
purchase
some of the unused storage at a high
level
accurate and you're the expert here but
is that direction
you're really accurate you know the only
thing i think i would uh sort of
uh clarify is that the drives that
you're using aren't necessarily
in uh in the data centers right so we've
got we've got
some people who have you know we've got
companies who have data centers we've
got universities have data centers
uh you've also got lots of individuals
who are running computers in their
basements
um and all of those you know people in
rural parts of the world that have
you know have a have a disk drive right
all of those can be part of our storage
network and lr
right so we've got um something like 10
000 drives
all around the world or 10 000 people
all around the world operating drives
like 85 countries
um and you know collectively they've
created a pretty massive storage network
and uh
if you are storing data with us instead
of us storing it on you know one drive
that we control
we sort of split it up into pieces and
we run it across large numbers
by lots of different people that not
only good economically it also turns out
to be really good for
privacy for cost for performance
and so the customer experience from what
i understand is
almost identical to what you would do
with a centralized service right you go
to a website you say hey i need to spin
up some storage
you basically purchased that and uh what
happens from that point through a
centralized and a decentralized service
is different
but right for the customer um it's
pretty much exactly the same
yeah i mean that was our intent our
intent was to say that first our
customers are concerned
we suggest be a really fast really
secure
really cheap um uh really useful way of
doing storage that doesn't require them
to change the way that they operate
so we've got you know got lots of people
doing cool decentralized apps on us we
also have
you know massive numbers of people who
are doing traditional apps on us that
just happen to be doing it now
got it and so then what is the economic
benefit
because that's ultimately the people who
have this unused storage and they're
kind of offering it up
i love the example of airbnb these are
the people who have a home and they want
somebody to come stay in it right
talk about kind of the economic uh
difference obviously you're competing
with xero
right so they get nothing for their
unused stuff without you right how much
can they make or how does that work from
uh
from you you actually send them somebody
to use as a customer
sure sure so basically uh what
uh if you're a storage node operator or
um you basically download some code onto
your onto your drive if you will
um and for the most part stuff happens
in the background you don't even have to
pay attention right
and again you're not spending additional
money on power or equipment or people to
do this
um what we do as our economic model is
we
quote prices to our customers and
in essence about 60 percent of what we
make
from our customers goes back to the
network and so as
a storage node operator we quote you a
price based off of how much data you're
storing and how much data you're serving
up
um and you know depending on the size of
your
size of your drive and how much you're
storing um
you know you can make five ten dollars a
month for drives right um so
it's not you know it's not a standalone
business like being a miner
um but for many people it's a great way
of monetizing the revenue test
um and unlike being a miner
it doesn't take a lot of power it
doesn't take a lot of effort it doesn't
you know we we designed this so that
it's
it doesn't take specialized equipment to
do um this is an incentive model for
excuse me for the rest of us right
um and so as a result we we've got a
really broad group of
storage operators who are happily being
part of this and of course
we compensate them in our token which is
uh str
and so this is something that can be
spun up pretty quickly
right if i have unused storage and i can
actually spin it down as well let's say
if i need the storage or something like
that also yeah
it's pretty responsive that's right yeah
so so
um you know now now you're you're sort
of your reputation if you will
is based off of uh things like uptime
um and uh how long you store but if you
are since a data center that
has equipment that sits idle for most of
the year but you need to reclaim it
uh you know around the holiday shoppies
or something like that that's fine
we have we have ways for you to sort of
tell us hey i need to
reclaim my space and you push the data
doesn't push it to other people
got it and so the part of this
conversation i'm really really
interested in
is uh i'm going to uh say hey ben and
the rest of the team
uh they know what they're doing they're
going to execute perfectly
and they're gonna end up being you know
really really successful beyond their
wildest dreams
what does this do to the the centralized
players and how does the market
you know forces change and kind of the
competitive landscape
uh if that occurs sure sure well i mean
what you know we're
able to price profitably to ourselves
right it's something like a third of
what the um cloud providers
do today right and as as and and i think
as important as the fact that we can we
can price that way over time
economics should help us bring prices
down right there's more and more data
more and more drives get shipped all the
time and
all the things that we care about our
economics our performance our security
uh they all get better and better the
larger larger our network gets
um so what we think or we certainly hope
this does it actually does disrupt the
market
and we'll probably be ignored for some
period of time right but
eventually i think there needs to be a a
challenge to the large players and
unlike
you know unlike the other people who try
to go into centralized computing
i mean you know big players like oracle
and ibm and others have tried to enter
the
cloud computing space and even they
don't have
the massive amounts of capital and data
centers to compete against the amazons
but you know the the closest competitor
that the big three have
is alibaba who's you know whatever
number six i don't know in terms of
marketing
right so uh the i think the only way
that you compete against the large folks
who disrupt them is through
decentralization
and that's true for us in storage but
also you know on the compute side as
well there are lots of really
interesting decentralized
companies and decentralized networking
companies yeah and
really the advantage you have is you can
have a price that is you know 66 percent
lower you know give or take
because you don't have all of the
infrastructure costs and all the
expenses that
take to build out the storage right
you're basically just tapping into
unused storage that other people have uh
and it costs you nothing
um to actually tap into it yeah
absolutely right um i mean
and and and also we've we've managed to
you know not only build the equivalent
of some really large data centers but do
it all around the world
right so that we now have the ability to
offer cloud storage to people
in kenya right only if you're getting uh
if you're going to be getting movies
served from us they're going to be
coming from nairobi not from nebraska
right so it's also faster absolutely
and then talk a little bit about um as
you're
doing this what stops them from going
into
and trying to do a decentralized option
right can the amazons
the googles like is that the the kind of
natural step for them to try to compete
as they
uh start to feel threatened by you uh
well i mean i think it's like most
disruptive
technologies or the incumbents don't
don't tend to tend to do it because
they've got something that works really
really well right and then they they
have
all of their advantages you know their
data centers
and you know their uh you know their
ability to operate on razor thin
margins uh on equipment and their power
suppression
and their power supplies and their
requirements that doesn't help them
in competing with us right uh and so
eventually maybe they will um but i
think
uh at that point we will have achieved
our energy business
we'll have i know i've gotten uh some
incumbency advantages as well
we're doing doing what we do is has
really powerful economics but there's
also as you can imagine
uh different challenges how do you keep
it coordinated how do you make sure
files don't get lost how do you make
sure you keep the incentive structure
right how do you make sure there's
the right balance between people who
want to provide storage
absolutely and then talk a little bit
about um obviously as you're doing this
decentralized network uh people have to
get paid
right and so um there's this uh storage
token right s-t-o-r-j or um i think is
what it is
um and they're you know these tokens
have become
controversial in the uh crypto industry
the bitcoin community
thinks you know why not use bitcoin uh
everybody else thinks why not use
xyz token like just talk a little bit
about um
the use of this payment via a digital
token or digital currency and then kind
of why create your own versus use one
that already existed
sure sure so we um
uh you know as i said sort of clarifying
at least at least the way our economic
model works right now we
quote prices in dollars both for
customers and for
uh the snows with the suppliers uh and
then customers can either pay us in fiat
or
in our token uh and our suppliers get
paid in token and we
do a sort of spot conversion based off
of these systems um
but there are a lot of reasons why it's
great for us first of all again we're
we're now paying thousands of people in
85 plus countries
right uh sometimes small amounts
sometimes large amounts being able to do
it with
uh using our token being able to use
things like smart contracts really
really critical
um we've also programmatically built in
not only on the supply side but on the
demand side
so we've uh we've built a program we
call it the open source partner program
that also kind of turns things on the
head in terms of demand slides rather
than
hiring lots of sales people as you
talked about the centralized people
doing and then
you know essentially what the cloud
providers tend to do with the open
source
community is take great open source code
uh give it away for free
you know as a loss leader to drive more
compute and storage networking
we actually compensate the open source
company as a company so if they send
users and data our way we send money
back to them and we do it
programmatically
um so for us it makes the system work
much faster
much more reliably of course we
we funded our initial efforts um
for a large extent uh based off of
having a successful token sale back in
in may of 2017.
um and uh for us
it's the right way to do things uh it
also gives us
an opportunity to also further
differentiate ourselves where we're
trying to be
not only sort of enterprise grade in
terms of our storage but also
enterprise grade in terms of the
governance and management
got it and so do you feel like uh
eventually
um this is gonna force kind of digital
currencies what regardless of which one
it ends up being uh into um kind of this
entire cloud and storage world
where whether you are a decentralized or
centralized platform like they've got to
support it
or do you feel like you've got kind of
an advantage and kind of a wedge into a
market
where that's not gonna happen for a long
time and you guys will kind of enjoy the
the first mover advantage there
uh yes it's a good question i mean we uh
uh you know i don't know whether the uh
the crypto aspect of what we do ends up
being a barrier to entry or not
um i suspect that if it doesn't it's
it's less important than the
decentralized aspect of what we do
right i i mean we sort of internally say
uh you know um
you know blockchain is much bigger than
cryptocurrency decentralization is much
bigger than
blockchain and we think that's like
decentralized infrastructure in general
is much bigger than any of them that's
really the powerful thing
is give tools that push things to the
edge
and push push infrastructure into the
hands of you know thousands hopefully
millions of people you know around the
planet um
and that that's really the big
disruption and and
cryptocurrency and blockchain these are
all sort of primitives that enable that
but they're not the main story yeah and
one of the things that's really
interesting just in
computing in general to me is uh the
centralized players have been
trying to build kind of
pseudo-decentralized networks
that they control right what i mean by
that is all of these pops and kind of
localized
data centers and kind of infrastructure
that for those that are unfamiliar with
the space
they basically are just pushing
infrastructure from rather than having
one data center
in the u.s or or in one area how do we
kind of break it up and put it closer to
the user
but they still control it it feels like
it's already moving in the direction of
decentralization from an infrastructure
standpoint just
the ownership has stayed centralized you
guys really are saying hey we have
decentralized
ownership of the network and we have
decentralized infrastructure and
therefore that's the advantage right
right right and also we've designed
things so that you know we're not a
central point of failure right so for
example like if you're storing data with
us
we don't have any of the keys we have no
way of knowing what's being stored
uh no way of mining it no way of uh
compromising it and the same thing true
for the storage node operators so
you know one sort of sort of
clarification
about how things work with us if you
upload a file to us to store it with us
it gets encrypted so scrambled up with
keys that only you have
it then gets split up into lots of
pieces uh generally about 80 pieces
of which any 30 communities put it back
in each of those 80 pieces goes to a
different drive
run by different person on different
power supply and a different geographic
location
and that level of decentralization does
magic security
magic in terms of performance magic in
terms of
uh of economics as well right um and
that's really the key right it's not
that we
have created a network where we push
stuff out to the edge
we've enabled the network it's at the
edge
that's awesome um and to me like you
know
yeah i'm biased uh because i kind of
understood this more and more and more
but
uh it just feels like naturally this is
where the world has to head right like
you guys are just ahead
ahead of the curve yeah yeah no i i
think i think it has to write and i
think i think
this decentralized approach is really
the only way to create a viable
alternative to the centralized providers
and it's good a job they do and by the
way they they offer great services right
but
um you know again if data is the new oil
we don't we don't want we don't want
another rocket builder
and it's just a bad thing if if cloud
computing which
is the most important computing trend uh
is dominated by
you know three of the five largest
companies by market cap that's
and nobody else can get in that that's
just that's a bad bad situation
where do you go from here in terms of uh
you have to have the storage network
do you eventually go and compete on
other aspects of computing using the
same model
absolutely absolutely so i mean right
now you know we think
that there are so many other there are
lots of great companies that are trying
to solve the decentralized view problem
and so you know right now we're sort of
in partnership mode
um and maybe continuing partnership mode
maybe we introduced at some point
uh there's a there's a long road that we
need that a
long roadmap in front of us in terms of
taking uh the storage that we have right
now which is primarily
uh used for sort of like fast backup and
things like that and extending it to
content delivery
and some compliance storage absolutely
you know
compute network and storage are
basically the three things that
are you know cloud computing and if you
can provide those primitives well
in a decentralized way that that that
disrupts the market
and yeah we've already found a great way
of getting
compatibility through providing the
incentive structure for open source in
the same way that
it would provide instant structure for
storage operators
and so when you built the kind of
decentralized storage network you also
you obviously have to go find these
people you have to explain it to them
you've got to get them on board and kind
of all that stuff
uh would it be fair to say that um those
same people who are providing storage
today
could be the starting point of the
network for computing or
or networking and these other services
and therefore it's almost like
yeah by building the first network then
the second third fourth and fifth get
easier and easier over time
yeah absolutely right i mean so if
you're if you're running a drive
uh you that that drive already has some
compute power in it
um and it's got some connectivity so
it's already kind of got like networking
and uh computing and now there's there's
different technical challenges to do
compute
securely and to do networking the right
way um but yeah absolutely
absolutely um uh
and uh you know the other sort of
there's also a whole bunch of other
learnings that you just have to get
around how do you run a discipline
how do you keep how do you keep supply
and demand in in
check i mean that that's one of the i
think the biggest challenge is that
uh you know doing what we do uh
has with the same way like you know if
you're uber or lyft
you know you want to have enough cars on
the road so that uh
anybody can always get a ride but you
don't want so many cars on the road that
nobody gets a affair right and so we're
the same thing everyone should do enough
there's enough to pass the outdoors and
anybody wants to start controlling but
you know people aren't sitting sitting
higher and is it also
true on the customer side so if i'm a
customer of your decentralized storage
then i probably also
the most likely to convert on
decentralized computing and other
services as well so it kind of
lower cost of acquisition i think so i
think so
um i mean uh
you know what what is what is true
though right now is that um
we have a lot of people who are doing
really cool decentralized apps on us
and we can talk about that in a bit but
um still the bulk of our customers
are people who are running more
traditional apps
they just want a better alternative than
storing the data uh
at the cloud providers
but you know i think what you tend to
see in technology in general right is
that
you know even the early adopters start
with
you know low um low risk
workloads and when you do a good job
with them then they start going
going upstream and that's that's kind of
the classic descent you know disruptive
approach you offer something that's
radically better
for a small number of use cases that the
big folks don't care about and once
when people get used to that then
suddenly you get more and more use cases
and higher and higher use cases and
before you know it
the people who are ignoring you are
chasing after you i was walking you into
explaining that you're essentially
putting the big guys in the innovator's
dilemma
right which is abs absolutely
they can't uh they can't come do what
you're doing because it would be a
distraction it doesn't look interesting
you know whatever but you get to uh
continue to kind of eat the stack of
infrastructure right so on that kind of
supply side and then as you
start to source demand you essentially
just eat more and more of their
computing needs
uh and next thing you know you back into
the centralized players not being in a
very good position
that's that's right and you know
honestly they you know they follow the
innovators dilemma too right i mean you
know
you know 12 years ago people say like
when you store data in a data center run
by somebody else that's crazy
crazy talk uh these are you know
low end use cases and move my way up and
we're doing the same thing and you know
if you read innovative dilemma you know
that the the
case study that that clayton christensen
did
was on stork because the storage
industry is just it's it's it's this is
this history of
uh innovators all the time
well we uh i'm cheering for you i hope
that that is what uh where the world is
going i
i do too but uh you know it's a it's an
exciting time really i think uh if
you're gonna go into
into startups and again this is my
eighth startup you've gotta do something
that you think is gonna be fun and
meaningful even if it isn't
absolutely before we get into uh the
rapid fire to uh to wind this down
i want to talk about real world use
cases and obviously um
you have so many uh customers kind of on
each side of the marketplace maybe talk
through you know one or two examples of
the types of infrastructure providers
and the types of companies that are
actually using this
sure sure sure so i'll uh i'll talk
about um
customers people who are actually
storing data with us right um and it's a
pretty
broad group of people um
we've got uh you know we've got people
who are storing
video and uh and photos and things like
that and
we give them a fast easy way to share
data we're seeing a lot of usage
among academic uh data sets right now
right where
you've got a massive data set of let's
say climate data or
uh energy data you know or health data
and you want to be able to share that
securely with large numbers of people
make it really fast to get it out there
we're just an excellent solution for
doing that because it's it's
very secure very durable and yet the
data can get extremely fast
everybody wants to use it um we're also
seeing some more
uh you know more relevant to probably
the earlier that you spent
spend time in we've got a few people who
are actually using us as a way to get
blockchain data distributed so
blockchains themselves are pretty
massive right and
in an ideal world it's really easy for
anybody who's running a node
to be able to get the entire blockchain
and get it quickly
ethereum classic wrote about how they're
using us but lots of others were using
as well
um to get uh get data out there and get
it
distributed quickly and secure
interestingly part of what you get when
you decentralize
storage is you get this massive
improvement in privacy and security
so as i mentioned you know every file
that gets uploaded to us
gets encrypted before it gets uploaded
then gets split up into
80 pieces each of which goes to a
different drive on the network that only
knows that they have a piece
and so if a hacker wanted to get at that
file they'd have to find
80 drives out of you know you know
thousands or hundreds of thousands
compromise each one all they would get
would be an encrypted file and even if
they managed to somehow depict that
the next file they go after is gonna be
different so if you're storing like
you know really sensitive personal data
we're a great solution
uh you remember a few years ago equifax
got breached
you know so millions of people's
personal data got compromised
because one going competent
administrator equifax
configured a print server incorrectly
with us that just can't happen right not
only
can we screw up but you can't scroll
because then
so that's those are the kinds of use
cases that we're seeing is
highly secure highly fast highly private
data that needs to get
stored and distributed globally is sort
of our sweet spot
and are there situations where companies
are choosing kind of centralized and
decentralized
uh solutions side by side so i may be a
company i've got some storage
you know needs and i may actually split
this between both centralized and
decentralized
um yeah maybe talk a little bit about
that yeah yeah i mean so
so um you know most of our our customers
you know right now have some data that
they're storing locally in their own
data center and then some data that
they're storing let's say an amazon or
google or
you know or microsoft um and journal
speaking what they will do with us is
they'll say okay i'm going to give you
10
of my new and i'm going to try you out
and so
you know every day as i'm running jobs
and creating data i'm going to push my
my backups to you or my snapshots to you
and see how you do
and then over time what they're what
they're saying is gosh
this is great rather giving you 10 of
the new data i create
let me give you 50 70 of the data that i
create
and then at some point they may take the
data that they're currently storing into
amazon
that's that'll be great but um you know
what i think is uh as sort of an
important truism is that if you're going
to be doing something disruptive
it can be disruptive but you don't want
to be you don't want your customers to
experience it
in a revolutionary way you want to give
them the opportunity to experience in an
evolutionary
[Music]
explain that that is very very good
advice but explain that
sure i i mean we as a brand new company
can take on lots and lots of risks right
if our but our customers um
you know most customers don't want to
have to change what they're doing
in order to get advantage i mean to ask
a customer to completely change
everything that they do how they write
their code how they
how they store it what their risk
profile is is asking a lot
right and so what we'd like to do is be
able to give people
you know the ability to say hey i'm
going to change three lines of code
suddenly i'm using storage and it's
cheaper faster better
more secure i love it and i'm gonna
evolve to do more and more over time
with
with us and you know you know the more
they do with us the more
uh benefit they can get but asking them
to change their world
for us is a non-starter
that uh that makes sense what's the
biggest challenges uh as you guys kind
of move forward
what do you spend your time thinking the
most about that you guys need to either
solve for
uh or kind of come up with solutions uh
sure i mean you know we spent a ton of
time making sure that we offered a
centralized storage solution that was
you know
high availability high performance had a
large enough number of nodes
um ran really well we actually had a
year-long beta process
uh you know we didn't single file which
was important
for us but making sure that what we were
offering was rock solid we
the last thing we wanted to do was be
the first
to market with a decentralized storage
system have people get excited about it
and then
and then fail because we wouldn't just
be failing for ourselves we'd be failing
for the whole industry
um uh so we spend a lot of time doing
that we spend a lot of time on
incentives
we want to make it really you have the
right incentives in place for people who
are running the notes
that they're profitable and easy and
they're not
they're not disappointed by what they
have and they also that we don't set the
wrong incentives right
we don't want to incent bad behavior
then a lot of it is you know the normal
blocking channel and building a great
company building great culture uh
building a great community
um and you know that's that's a
challenge but it's also really fun but
ultimately
the community is so much larger than the
company and the company is so much
larger
okay that's a great way to look at it uh
i asked the same two questions to
everybody
and then you'll get to ask me one to uh
to finish up uh the first one is what is
the most
important book that you've ever read
well we talked about one of them already
which was innovative
that's great uh and lately i've
uh i've been rereading uh man's search
for meaning me
why do you like that one so much
um i think you know we're living in
like unusually difficult times and
and i think uh you know hey you know
having the perspective
of people who were facing challenges
that just sort of swamp anything we're
dealing with
yeah it's annoying to have to sit on
your butt and watch tiger king but
that's not the best
um you know to understand how to sort of
accept the situation you're in and yet
still have hope and i think is really
really important um and and so
you know i think in times like this i
find that an inspirational
and also understand the importance of
being kind to each other and having
broader
broader meaning in your life i think
part of how you get through difficult
times like we're going through is to
work on something that's larger than
yourself um
so you'll love the second question it's
a little bit more fun but man search for
meaning has a connection here which is
aliens uh believer believer or
non-believer
uh i absolutely believe that there's
life teaming in the universe and there's
lots of intelligent life
uh i'm not convinced that they've come
to visit earth and certainly
2020 i'm sure there's if they are out
there they're staying far far away
i i've always thought about like do we
want to find them or do we want them to
find us
right usually at least in human history
like the the conqueror has
prevailed uh yeah i don't know in 2020
like this is probably not the planet you
want to just
jet on over to if uh if you had a choice
yeah i guess so yeah the alien cortez
equipment is looking at us and saying
yeah
i don't i don't think so we'll wait till
2021 to go visit
one yeah you could ask me one question
to finish up what uh what one question
do you have for me
um so what's next after d flight what
are you most excited about
look i i think um i'm very convinced
that
centralization has now become a business
risk obviously
um and so whether that is centralization
of your infrastructure like what you
guys are going after
um centralization of kind of financial
services so everything from bitcoin on
down to some of the the more nuanced
deepvi
stuff um is kind of the where the world
is headed
one of the things that is um really
really interesting to me as a concept
is this idea that uh we have entire
frameworks currencies rules
etc uh for every economy
and every uh kind of business um you
know market
but they're all tied to you know
essentially imaginary lines on a map
right so they're all fit like physical
location based type world
um and in some weird uh
potentially wrong but but still kind of
exciting world
i kind of think of it as like you and i
uh both left our geographic
locations today and we met in the
internet
you know economy right and so we're
doing this virtually
and so it's kind of like ready player
one style you know like like
you're going into this like internet
economy or this internet world
um and so when you think of it that way
uh and you kind of take you know
pre-covered
all the things you would do right so
everything from you might go to a happy
hour with your
colleagues you had to go to work um you
know you'd go to your kids ball game
like you kind of just walked through
every single you know daily activities
what percent and which ones are going to
end up in this like internet world so
yeah you're obviously not going to be
able to virtually attend your
kids virtual baseball game like that
might be a little weird
right yeah at least in the short term um
and so like
some of it is not going to kind of you
know be
brought into this yeah but when you
start to bring some of this in so
meetings is the the easy example for
everybody
there's entirely new businesses there's
all kinds of decentralization you know
benefits like
there's just a lot that would change and
i think that
for you and i who you know generally are
technology-minded have kind of been
paying attention to a lot of these
trends
if anything it just accelerated things
we kind of already knew were underway
but i think a lot about like you know
restaurants
like all of a sudden a lot of
restaurants were like oh this digital
thing's gonna happen you know
five or ten years from now and like we
just got a website right
it's like no now now it's here oh now
you got here like overnight accelerated
everything
and so you know those are like digital
examples i also think that you start to
um break down this idea of like if
companies start to pursue
more resilience um and not just
efficiency they're gonna
onshore a lot of things right so you're
gonna see all kind of manufacturing
supply chains like all that stuff
um and so in that trend
uh american labor is actually pretty
expensive compared to where they've been
able to outsource it and so the unit
economics get thrown off
and so i think like there'll be this
resurgence of um
i don't like 3d manufacturing and
automation and all these things that
allow technology to to kind of
bring the cost of that stuff back down
but based here in uh in north america
and so when you think of that like we
do we have enough people to do that like
that are skilled
i i don't know right and so i don't know
it's just things like that i spend time
thinking about and
it's probably uh intellectually uh
stimulating for me because there's not a
right answer
right so like you can't be wrong
[Music]
so i don't know but for you guys right
it's like a perfect you know uh
tailwind right because basically
everyone's gonna need storage everyone's
gonna need computing power
and kind of you'll benefit from this
digitization of everything really
absolutely yeah you know i think uh you
know
it's other other uh things if you're
gonna go into a startup you should
you should be have the waves moving in
your direction right now
i'm not not going against them
death taxes and data and cloud all sort
of
pretty close i forget who says it but
somebody's like uh
you know uh good team bad market market
wins
uh okay team good market market wins
right and so it's kind of like you know
just make sure you're rowing in the
direction of uh
of where the waves are going you'll be
all right absolutely
awesome ben listen thank you so much for
taking the time to do this where can
people find you on the internet uh or
find out more about storage if they want
to uh go check it out
yes we're uh we're uh storage strj.io
and uh you'll go there if you want to
become a storejoint operator if you want
to become a customer
both uh great place to go um and i'm uh
at gallup be on twitter if you want to
follow me
awesome man listen thank you so much for
doing this and we'll have to do it again
in the future
okay thanks man